in his first weeks as the new
commissioner Mark Rowley singled out
dealing with mental health issues as a
major distraction for his officers
too many hours spent waiting with
patients in hospital emergency centers
not enough time said the commissioner
preventing and fighting crime
retired met police officer Chris Hobbs
blamed Public Health spending cuts the
only one I remember dealing with was
someone threatening suicide from the top
of a bus garage
now we managed to talk him down got him
on the floor and we just took him across
the road to where there was a very large
Mental Health Hospital mental health
hospitals have closed or been reduced in
size the whole Mental Health Service is
under stress so the police have had to
pick up the slack and basically they
said well we can't we can't do this
anymore
the commissioner says from the end of
August his officers will stop answering
emergency calls involving mental health
patients unless life is at risk
in a letter to Health and Social care
providers Sir Mark Rowley wrote every
day that we permit the status quo to
remain we are collectively failing
patients and are not setting up officers
to succeed in fact we are failing
londoners twice we are failing them
first by sending police officers not
medical professionals to those in Mental
Health crisis We are failing London as a
second time by taking large amounts of
Officer time away from preventing and
solving crime as well as dealing
properly with victims he said officers
were spending more than 14 hours handing
patients over to medical staff taking up
10 000 hours of Officer time each month
last month he said only 30 percent of
999 calls were actually crime related I
think it is worrying for for patients
and service users and mental health to
think that in London at the end of
August there is no other number to call
at the moment there is only 99 9 that
relatives can call when someone's in
that crisis and that's not going to
change between now and the 30th 30th of
August Scotland Yard has called for an
urgent meeting with health Chiefs
the commissioner is confident in his
threat to stop responding to all but
life-threatening mental health crises
because he knows it's worked elsewhere
a pilot scheme in humberside brought
police health and charity staff together
it's been praised by the police
inspectorate for giving patients better
care and freeing up crime resources
model known as right care right person
it could be adopted nationally
eventually but the Met says it can't
wait for that Martin brunt Sky News at
New Scotland Yard